In the previous
chapter, we discussed
how to encode information
as sequences of bits.
In this chapter, we
turn our attention
to finding a useful
physical representation
for bits, our first
step in building devices
that can process information.
So, what makes a
good bit, i.e., what
properties do we want our
physical representation of bits
to have?
Well, we’ll want a lot of them.
We expect to carry
billions of bits
around with us,
e.g., music files.
And we expect to have access
to trillions of additional bits
on the web for
news, entertainment,
social interactions, commerce
— the list goes on and on.
So we want bits to be
small and inexpensive.
Mother Nature has a suggestion:
the chemical encoding embodied
in DNA, where sequences of the
nucleotides Adenine, Thymine,
Guanine and Cytosine
form codons that
encode genetic
information that serve
as the blueprint for
living organisms.
The molecular scale meets our
size requirements and there’s
active research underway on how
to use the chemistry of life
to perform interesting
computations on a massive
scale.
We’d certainly like our bits
to be stable over long periods
of time — “once
a 0, always a 0!”
The Rosetta Stone, shown here
as part of its original tablet
containing a decree from
the Egyptian King Ptolemy V,
was created in 196 BC and
encoded the information needed
for archeologists
to start reliably
deciphering Egyptian
hieroglyphics almost 2000
years later.
But, the very property
that makes stone engravings
a stable representation
of information
makes it difficult to
manipulate the information.
Which brings us to the final
item on our shopping list:
we’d like our representation of
bits to make it easy to quickly
access, transform,
combine, transmit and store
the information they encode.
Assuming we don’t want to carry
around buckets of gooey DNA
or stone chisels, how
should we represent bits?
With some engineering we
can represent information
using the electrical
phenomenon associated
with charged particles.
The presence of
charged particles
creates differences in
electrical potential energy
we can measure as voltages, and
the flow of charged particles
can be measured as currents.
We can also encode information
using the phase and frequency
of electromagnetic fields
associated with charged
particles — these latter
two choices form the basis
for wireless communication.
Which electrical phenomenon
is the best choice
depends on the
intended application.
In this course, we’ll use
voltages to represent bits.
For example, we might choose
0V to represent a 0-bit and 1V
to represent a 1-bit.
To represent
sequences of bits we
can use multiple
voltage measurements,
either from many
different wires,
or as a sequence of voltages
over time on a single wire.
A representation using
voltages has many advantages:
electrical outlets provide an
inexpensive and mostly reliable
source of electricity and,
for mobile applications,
we can use batteries
to supply what we need.
For more than a century, we’ve
been accumulating considerable
engineering knowledge about
voltages and currents.
We now know how to build very
small circuits to store, detect
and manipulate voltages.
And we can make those circuits
run on a very small amount
of electrical power.
In fact, we can
design circuits that
require close to zero power
dissipation in a steady state
if none of the encoded
information is changing.
However, a voltage-based
representation
does have some challenges:
voltages are easily affected by
changing electromagnetic fields
in the surrounding environment.
If I want to transmit
voltage-encoded information
to you, we need to be
connected by a wire.
And changing the
voltage on a wire
takes some time since the
timing of the necessary flow
of charged particles is
determined by the resistance
and capacitance of the wire.
In modern integrated circuits,
these RC time constants
are small, but sadly not zero.
We have good engineering
solutions for these challenges,
so let’s get started!